[Music]
so what would you guys do
if you found out
you could spend 1.6 million dollars
and it's not your money and nobody
really kind of knows that you're even
doing this by using an atm exploit what
and it's perfectly legal they can get
you way later on that [ __ ] though what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
but if it's uh i'll get away with it and
then i get caught when i'm 80 something
years old i'm down yeah what would you
do though with the money one point first
off
i'm gonna go to [ __ ] texas roadhouse
because you know
that's so good
you know they're [ __ ] bread bro
they're good it's good and it's
unlimited what kind of breath they have
texas toast no no the the first the
dinner roll one the one that they bring
out oh it's like buttery and you just
sit there and you just break the bread
you go
oh uh i'll just have this you know and
then
the basket's completely done and then
the waiter comes back would you like
another one i'm like oh i really
shouldn't but yeah i'll get another one
it's free you know and then you go
it's gone and you're like oh [ __ ] what
i'm gonna do and they're like sorry the
food's so like don't worry just bring
another [ __ ] basket of bread out
we'll be okay and by the time the food
comes out you're not even hungry no more
so you actually get two meals
fire take it home it's kind of like a
fetch new end like tutorial
okay first you want to get the [ __ ]
deal right did you get two mules or you
take the whole thing
you put it into anchor protocol
and then even if you get caught you just
give the 1.2 million back but everything
else you earn you keep you're 300 bucks
a day
i'd put it in alice actually
yeah with what seven dollars seven
dollars fifty cents yeah do you get off
the hook when you're like oh okay i'll
turn the money back
you know do you get off the hook when
you steal and you go okay so i'm saying
if you get caught you gotta give back
anyway but then at least you were able
to earn money you gave it back that's
true if you give a good idea 10x that
[ __ ] you're like a safe thief
so i just spent it on dinner there's a
bartender
there's a bartender in australia he
found out like he was late one night
he's taking 200 out of an atm and he's
like okay give me 200 and
the it's like uh oh air he's like okay
well i'll transfer
from my savings to my checking
and then
he was able to pull out 200 no problem i
got a [ __ ] machine [ __ ] up
so then he he tried it again um because
he was like wait he's like wait that
minute work and then it worked he's like
okay i guess it worked so then he said
um
it was like a magic trick and the next
day he woke up and he thought
wait did i kind of just double my money
last night and it didn't really take out
of my balance and then he checked it
he calls and he checks and he there was
nothing that was taken out of his
account so he kept doing it
so he realized that at this certain time
of night
there was a moment in between when the
atm
knows what's like guards or changing
shifts yeah
so he starts to just pull [ __ ] cash
out of this machine at that time i
didn't know it was the time and not
anything else oh no he's a smart drunk
dude
dude
smartest drunk dude i've ever heard
about pretty sweet how do you know at
what time so if he did this between one
and three in the morning he realized he
could create the money out of thin air
and it would actually deposit so like so
he's like a stimulus check so yeah but
he didn't have to withdraw it so he
would just go checking uh he'll go
savings to checking and it would just
balance that amount into his checking
and then his savings stayed the same so
he's like
are you [ __ ] kidding me so he moved
over a million dollars over the span
and the best part is when he went to the
bank or he called in his balance so he
did both he's like hey what's my balance
like
a million dollars and he's like what
the [ __ ] you talking about so then so
then he's just
so then he's just like
okay well let's start to have the
[ __ ] time of our lives so he pays off
he has a lot of friends who are in
college he's paying off their tuitions
wow that's what he did that's tough he's
buying bar tabs he's already a bartender
but then he's like he's like hey
you know all that kind of [ __ ] right wow
then he's like taking money he's like
buying trips he's like paying for things
nothing really too crazy but definitely
like
enough to raise eyebrows if you knew him
and you weren't asking questions so
we're like how are you it's like what
they did in good fellas i told you not
to buy the [ __ ] car you idiot
yes
yes
his friends get jealous so then his
friends rat him out no
not those friends dude this this guy did
such a good job with this exploit that
nobody even [ __ ] knew
for years oh
until he started vlogging i'm imagining
getting away for years he starts to get
a guilty conscience about it oh no he
turns himself in
kinda so by the time that like years
went by right he talks about it he goes
to the bank
and he's like hey i want to have a
conversation about like my
atm stuff and then they're like we can
no longer talk about this because it's a
police investigation so then he's
already like okay i've already been
thinking about this i'm so [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] am i gonna do
but the best part is
when he went to trial with this like
like even later than that he'd wait like
three years to go to trial so he kept
using the money while he was scared no
no he stopped eventually like after like
a year he stopped and then he
wanted to do the right thing so we saw
like a psychologist and and like the
first psychologist he saw was like yo we
uh shouldn't be talking about this the
next one he talked to they were able to
discuss the stuff with him a little more
openly and then he's like okay i'm gonna
turn myself in you went to the same one
the [ __ ] um the mob boss went to on
the [ __ ] sopranos
but she died i think well i think
analyze this came out before that oh
really okay so he went to that one yeah
yeah but
still really good but no so he um he he
goes there and then they're like yeah
you should turn yourself in so then by
the time he tells them he's already
under investigation they can't talk
about it he waits to get popped so he's
like dreaming about every night he's
having dreams about the swat coming he
hears weird noises he thinks they're
coming for him it's just [ __ ] with
him goes to thewholekim.com yeah exactly
so so then um one day he finds himself
in court at last
but the prosecutor barely knows what the
[ __ ] he did they can't really figure out
wow
wow it's just that his bank account
precipitously gained money over a very
short they don't they can't prove that
it's here because they have the burden
of proof
that's right so they don't it's not that
they don't know that he did it because
he was like i'm ready to tell you guys
he was spending it he was taking it out
so like obviously he was like somewhat
involved duh right
but they just didn't understand it well
enough to really prosecute him so the
guy got a year
he didn't have to pay any penalties he
spent like one point [ __ ] five
million dollars
you have to pay it back either oh no not
that i could just be the most luckiest
guy on earth but i don't know how much
if those three years of stress was worth
it three years of stress and one year of
what
probation in prison you went to jail for
a year what a good conscience though
yeah i mean most people do how the heck
not me i'll escape the country
but not for 1.6 well he says he thought
about it he's like i'll go to mallorca
which is greece he's like i'll go i'll
get the [ __ ] out those are normal
thoughts so but for him to take that
money and then to like pay off his
friends college
and then still be like i need to go see
a psychologist because i'm like you know
that he's like a regular good dude he
said that when he was a millionaire
people just treated him different like
he would go to the bank and like
initially the teller didn't give a [ __ ]
and then they'd open his account and be
like oh hey like what's up like hey like
it was like he like it was like it was
just changed the way that people looked
at him the way they treated him he's
like when i went places and
you know you guys know how this show is
right yeah because you i walk in like
this and they're like
and then they they see the account they
go oh how can i help you sir remember
how you guys used to treat me before you
looked up my net worth yeah 18 million
dollars we're like [ __ ] miss those
days and i apologize for all i used to
treat you yeah
i just wish you would pay off our
tuition
you've done you're good
i did ucb dude i
have bills up the ass you got to pay
ucb's tuition now paying that [ __ ] does
it mention his age by any chance uh
must be cause like if that was happening
and i was in my early 20s that's
different from if i was in my early 30s
i would have felt more guilty than
because i was more christian and
understood less about government he was
29
because now it feels like [ __ ] these
guys dude they print money all day yeah
you know how many lives they crushed
and that's how i justify stealing yeah
that's a good way i guess it depends on
what you're doing with the money that's
you know robin hooding it
yeah well now he's back to making 22 an
hour because he served his time i'm
gonna make mr beast videos with it is
that not similar to what biden's about
to do when he erases that much debt from
everybody
randomly 10k per yeah that ain't gonna
happen bro and he's barely gonna do it
do you think i think he'll do a little
bit if he's gonna give us freaking
random money convenience that it's
happening right before election time
that no that's just absolutely they
couldn't he had a couple years to do it
but like took forever the combined
household has to be like 75k
for you to get 10k off your student debt
but 10k off is [ __ ] nothing to these
people 10k off of your 250 000 debt
being an engineer wall street's [ __ ]
they just print it and then they hand it
to them it's put a billion can't print
it and hand it to the people though
they'll never do it that's what i was
saying during cove i was like they could
hand everybody 20 g's and people like
steve it's so stupid this is a stupid
idea and i'm like that's actually like
that would be nice for people but
you know whatever it is
[Music]
you